hey guys if you bought one of my
sneakers I want you to buy one of my
wines listen make is it you got your
perspective
[Music]
why don't you why don't you guys both
come in we'll go make some content brats
Illinois's your bulls just got my homie
Carmelo Anthony scroll it up babban
scroll it up he's on your team and I
want to be on your wine team one of the
things you hey come on you got to hold
it together I'm gonna silly mood today
those transitions are the best put that
in the vlog when you get a chance all
right what's that noise no noise yeah
but I'm a lil annoys by my wines or a
sudden eight after you I want to go live
and sell some way let's go live I can't
see you there we go not yet but keep
going help me remember okay oh yeah what
I do remember that pair from the parents
no you don't know you don't this is the
number one mistake that everybody thinks
everybody thinks that they put them
their own self doubt on themselves it's
actually not how it works outside forces
got into your head and then made you
self doubt you think it's your voice
nobody's voice hates them in the
beginning it's a voice that's been
implanted in you either in the beginning
from your neighborhood and outside force
often parents and so where people get
really [ __ ] up is they think like like
when I talk about like don't listen to
the Joneses they're like [ __ ] you know I
don't care about other people it's that
I [ __ ] on myself and I'm trying to get
people to understand you're not [ __ ]
on yourself you've taken on the voice of
somebody from the outside you weren't
born with like I hate me you were you've
taken on the voice of somebody from the
outside it's very important that you
understand this
tell you why it gets a lot easier if you
actually believe it and understand it
because then you can understand it
versus laying there and being like why
do I hate myself you know what I mean
you don't somebody implanted their
insecurities on you it's what it's why a
lot of people get value out of me
because through my practical optimism
not my delusional urine eighth place
trophy but for my practical optimism if
people keep putting that voice in their
ears the reason people listen to so much
of my content is I'm optimistic but I'm
not gonna sugarcoat and be like if you
just wish it it happens and in that
balance over time if that's what goes
into your ears then all of a sudden you
start believing it like I genuinely
believe it I believe that the two of us
should never dress like doubt ourselves
why like I don't understand like go do
and deal with the rail like I think I
suck in most things but I need to go
find that out for myself not not do it
because I'm worried about somebody
judging me on my failure like this is
just the way it is I just I'm just
really happy that you're even like like
that we're interacting this much because
like honestly I just you know it's funny
I just want people to listen to me as
much as possible until they don't need
to listen to me and then I don't want
them to listen to me at all more
importantly listen to me this is binary
you need to act if you actually if used
this time that we've interacted this
time to understand that any level of
self-doubt or insecurity that you have
in your head
is literally been put inside of it and
it's not you doing it to you it will
change your [ __ ] young life our
orders coming in alright this there we
go
this is hold on let me look this is this
is this is the forum because you know
what it is
I put around it people haven't been able
to buy wine from Wine Library for a
decade in Illinois no [ __ ] noise in
Illinois Illinois you felt it you felt
it
what up dude
[Music]
I knew this is gonna happen today holy
[ __ ] sometimes like it's hard to things
two things I know [ __ ] of course it's
hard especially when you were built in a
framework where you value outside
opinion
one other thing based on you knowing I
was gonna call you today just random
just a random gut feeling what the
pick-6 lotto might be just give me six
numbers real quick go ahead 32 write
this down 32 I'm gonna tweet I'm gonna
tweet out these numbers 32 36 I love it
five beautiful got 20 that's four we're
good we need two more 29 and six so five
six nine twenty thirty two and 36
beautiful you got it you're gonna go
play it do it if you [ __ ] win the
lottery today I'm gonna lose my [ __ ]
dude I'm a hundred percent get anything
I expect all three thousand people how
many people they are about eight hundred
all right I expect all 4,000 people
magic hits if tomorrow I wake up and
there's a five six nine twenty thirty to
thirty six pick six somewhere I'm gonna
lose my [ __ ] and so is somebody who's
watching when it hits in Oregon and I
really [ __ ] like I love man all right
just drop keep doing it let's go disrupt
was fired up I'm glad I did that all
right somebody's this [ __ ] lottery
number hit somewhere
hey guys thank you so much for watching
my video on YouTube I wanted to jump in
here at the end because I'm working on a
ridiculously important project for me
and I have a funny feeling you can help
if you drink wine at all or know anybody
that drinks wine at all please go to
empathy wines calm right now and sign up
or a subscription whether it's a three
pack whether it's a six pack or whether
it's a whole case of each for the year
if you drink 36 bottles of wine a year
or give away 36 bottles of wine a year
please sign up for Club apathy this
project means the world to me
that could really use your support
[Music]